here's what happened to the England
France World Cup quarterfinal
it took less than 17 minutes for France
to find the back of the net
a long-range shot from aurelian to
chuomani stunned England France went up
1-0 after the goal England tried to
mount a response back-to-back attacks
were denied by Hugo yuris and the French
defense France went into the half on Top
seven minutes into the second half pukai
Osaka drew a penalty for England Harry
Kane took the kick and he scored it
then in the 78th minute Striker Olivier
Giroux fired a header on goal and scored
France took the lead again 2-1 with
darude's 53rd International goal
in the 81st minute Mason Mount was taken
down in the penalty area by Francis Teo
Hernandez the ref waved play on but
after a VAR review he called it back for
a penalty Harry Kane stepped up for his
second penalty of the night
Target after 90 minutes France kept lead
and held off England through more than
10 minutes of added time at the end
France moved on to the semi-final for
the second World Cup in a row
face Morocco
now
[Applause]